Natacha my sister after all this time
what brings you home I was trying to do
something doing
any more than just a trained killer
you're fooling yourself we're still both
trained killers
[Music]
we have unfinished business
as we
still fits family back together again
you got fat smelly waterway
there's a new Waldo when else
new enemies
I'm done running from my past
[Music]
that was that guy
black widows multilayered and you know
motivated and determined and she has an
art I would love to take this character
in every different direction always
picking up after you boys the
possibilities are really endless before
I worked for shield make mistakes but
I'm done running from my past very few
actors can say that they've worked on a
character for ten years and then this
chance to delve deep into this person we
have to go back to where it all started
there's one movie people have been
asking us to make for a very long time
more so than any other film the black
widow movie
I'm just excited to see the real Black
Widow she's not a classic hero because
she has a dark past what brings you home
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my brand new Black Widow
trailer video there's a whole bunch of
new footage we get a much better look at
taskmaster vs. black widows so we'll
break it all down if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the easter-egg videos we're doing a
movie ticket giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
all your predictions about the black
widow movie so this footage is mostly
focusing on black widows family her
going home quote-unquote to Budapest
there's this theme of her two different
families like she talks about her new
family the Avengers that she got later
after she joined shield most of the
events of this movie because it's a
flashback will be about the family that
she got when she was part of the Red
Room
Black Widow program they jump all over
the timeline but I think that most of
you have probably got a sense for where
she is based on the different costumes
that she wears like the very classic
looking comic book II Black Widow
uniform with the gold gauntlets seems
like it's from very early in the
timeline before she joined shield than
all the scenes with them in the white
uniforms is from later when they go to
destroy the Red Room program in Siberia
here during the big third act battle so
if you're ever confused about where she
is in the timeline and when certain
scenes are taking place what year just
think about the costumes that she's
wearing during them but at the beginning
of the footage she quote-unquote goes
home to Budapest and it even seems like
she used to live in this apartment
building because she has what looks like
a secret compartment where she stashed a
gun a long time ago and she's just going
to get it before she goes to meet with
Jelena Bulova there are a couple of
different scenes of what seems like this
apartment building - like there's a
fight scene where someone blasts through
the ceiling and comes down in but she's
wearing her old Black Widow uniform so
it seems like it's a flashback and not
connected to these scenes of yell and a
Bulova talking to her
Jelena Bulova literally calls her sister
but I've seen so many news outlets
getting this idea wrong they're not
literal biological sisters as far as we
know Natasha doesn't have any biological
brothers or sisters they're sisters like
the Avengers become brothers in arms
they become like a family they're not
literal biological family she says she's
on the run you see what looks like a
giant team of Swat agents trying to
catch her at a train station still in
the United States so these are all
probably happening right after the
events of Captain America Civil War like
she had that voiceover dialogue with
Thunderbolt Ross in the last trailer
about what her plans were what she was
going to do next
they show you that she's also on the run
when she's back in Budapest from the
brand-new black widows like later in the
trailer she talks about there being a
new generation of black widows when they
show these scenes of them training so if
it wasn't clear this chick on the roof
with the sniper rifle is just one of
many brand-new black widows there's some
scenes later in the trailer that make it
seems like she also tried to destroy the
Black Widow program in the flashbacks so
I'll explain that in a second too my
guess is is that's probably why the Red
Room wants her dead and they're sending
all these black widows after her in
present-day because she tried to do
something in the past to get rid of them
she tells me on a Bulova that she was
trying to do something good be more than
just a trained killer she's talking
about how she got herself into trouble
during Captain America Civil War in
right now her mission in Budapest and
Russia is a continuation of that idea to
take down the Red Room and end the Black
Widow program permanently there's also
this idea that Jelena Bulova is kind of
like a little sister to her a surrogate
little sister so through her actions
she's trying to teach her that she can
also be more than that be more than a
trained killer Jelena Bulova is being a
little more cynical about it no you're
wrong we're just trained killers that's
all we are I think part of her arc
during the film is going to be realizing
that no I can be good to in eventually
early prediction after the events of
Avengers endgame she will take the
mantle of Black Widow and carry on her
legacy in a slightly different way she
won't be the same type of Black Widow
that Natasha was there's this really
brief but a really funny moment though
when they're all trying to talk about
what their plans are what they're going
to do next and she walks out of what
looks like the most hardcore weapons
locker that she's assembled in this
small apartment building just look at
the small Arsenal that she has they do a
bunch of jump cuts but like I said I
think this is a flashback and it might
wind up being Hawkeye vs. Black Widow in
Budapest because they keep referencing
Budapest you remember Budapest very
differently during the course of the
Avengers movie I think at some point
there's going to be a Hawkeye cameo and
it'll be a reference to what actually
happened when he and her work together
in Budapest sometimes way before the
events of Marvel phase 1 so obviously
there's all the stuff happening in
present day with Jelena Bulova in
Budapest but I think that we'll also see
another flashback before Marvel phase 1
it's connected to her wearing this
classic uniform with the gold gauntlets
she references her family having
unfinished business then you see a bunch
of new scenes of red Guardian Wrecking
the other Russian prisoners in this
Siberian prison the way David Harper
talks about his character is that he
says that he's a failed version of
Captain America he was supposed to be
this grand experiment Russia was so
proud to create him and for whatever
reason he wound up being this big
failure so it's not clear why he was
thrown in this Siberian prison maybe he
rebelled against them maybe he just
didn't do a good job or didn't live up
to their expectations so we'll lock you
in prison for the next 10 to 15 years
and just throw away the key and forget
about you David Harper also revealed
that the Red Guardian character was kind
of like a surrogate father to Natasha
growing up so I guess that makes Rachel
vices character her surrogate mother you
also see some new scenes of her in one
of the white black widow uniforms in
what seems like the big third act battle
when they go to the Red Room program to
blow it up later you get a whole bunch
of footage from that bridge fight scene
of Black Widow versus taskmaster this is
actually really badass I believe it
comes a little earlier in the film
before you see taskmaster fighting Red
Guardian later when they're in Siberia
he looks way better with the hood up
he's fighting with his sword and his
shield here obviously this is a
reference to Captain America using his
shield so remember
taskmaster instantly learns everyone's
moves because he's using Captain America
moves like that's what this shield throw
is supposed to be a reference to like oh
wow he's clearly studied caps moves but
when did that happen a lot of people are
confused about this taskmaster doesn't
need to physically fight someone to
learn their moves he could actually just
watch footage of Captain America and
learn his moves that way so taskmaster
could literally have just watched all
this archival footage of the different
Avengers characters fighting in that's
how he learned their moves you also
noticed too she lands a couple head
shots during their fight direct head
shots up close range but because he's
wearing his special helmet they just
bounce right off I love the look on her
face too when she realizes that he's
copying her moves like what the hell is
this guy's deal a lot of people still
wondering who the secret identity of
taskmaster is I seriously think that
it's this guy here they brought him up
on stage at Comic Con said he was a main
character but refused to say what the
name of his character he was playing was
going to be they're just calling him
quote-unquote Mason but I think that's
gonna be a fake name and they'll have
some way of explaining taskmaster MC use
backstory in weaving it in with the
history of the Black Widow program so
that he has some sort of history with
them but I am hoping that they leave
tasks
you're alive at the end of the movie so
that he could potentially join some sort
of Thunderbolts project or even a Dark
Avengers team in the future all these
scenes of her flying through this giant
explosion midair while being chased by
these other people all seems like it's
happening in flashbacks because she's
still wearing the old black widow
costume with the goal of gauntlets then
during that behind-the-scenes clip
Scarlett Johansson talks about taking
the character in a bunch of different
directions going forward that doesn't
mean that she's coming back to life
after avengers endgame that just means
that there's potential for them to do
more black widow sequels but they'd also
be said during the past during some
other part of her timeline they could
theoretically do more sequels if the
first movie is successful but they could
also do Disney Plus series I personally
rather see them do a Disney Plus series
if they want to do a bunch of black
widows stories but I'm not gonna hold my
breath on any kind of black widow
sequels there's way too many other new
characters they need to introduce like
the new Deadpool characters x-men
Fantastic Four characters I'd rather see
those movies before they think about
doing any more Black Widow sequels but
what'll happen is is I have a much more
Morbius spider-man videos coming later
this week there's a bunch more Marvel
stuff the finale of crisis on Infinite
Earths is also happening tonight so I'll
be doing episode videos for that
congratulations tyrone long you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details every one click here for the
brand new Morbius trailer with the
spider-man scene in that very special
cameo and click here for my new Avengers
Iron Man Marvel phase four announcement
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]